five funerals were held on thursday in
one of the deadliest days in the
occupied west bank in recent months
the palestinian victims were all killed
during confrontations with israeli
forces
this funeral is for 20 year old omar
alayan from silhad village near ramallah
paramedics told us the israeli army
delayed ambulances and assaulted them
before finally allowing them to reach
lyan 20 minutes after he was shot by
then
it was too late to save him
my son's only wish was to die for what
he believed in just like his whole
generation because they see no future
nor a political horizon for them
the palestinian red crescent says since
the beginning of this month medical
teams have been blocked from aiding the
wounded in five different incidents
in the past two weeks three attacks on
medical staff and another on an
ambulance were reported
two of those killed on thursday were
from jeanine north of the west bank
janine has become the center of the
current wave of escalation with almost
daily raids by israeli forces
hundreds of gunmen live in the janine
refugee camp and often return israeli
fire with fire
youth and ramallah are raging i'm not
only talking about me i know how every
young man is feeling the youth in
ramallah are all ready for escalation we
can't accept to just sit and watch our
brothers in genin and nablus and other
areas while they're resisting and being
killed and injured
the israeli military says it's
conducting a counter-terrorism operation
it started early april after two gunmen
from the jeanine area committed two
attacks in israel leaving eight israelis
dead palestinian prisoners groups say
israeli forces have arrested more than
200 palestinians since the operation
started but tensions stretch back longer
than that
since the beginning of the year more
than 1500 palestinians have been
detained and at least 41 palestinians
have been killed the majority in
confrontations with the israeli military
we're not just talking about the latest
attacks in israel as a starting point
for the current escalation yes indeed it
has contributed to heightened tensions
all across the west bank but
palestinians want the world to know that
they have been under occupation for
decades and it's rarely been a night in
the west bank where they haven't seen
the israeli army raid their cities
arrest people and sometimes shoot and
kill them
on thursday a general strike was
announced in three cities in the west
bank ramallah bethlehem and jeanine to
mourn the dead
palestinians fear that there will be
more israeli raids in the days ahead
ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied west
bank